Good to see you, Don.
How are you?
What's goin' on, Conan?
I didn't see you, man.
How are you?
[Conan] I'm good.
I like that you were making fun of my hair
just before we got started,
'cause it's outta control and I apologize.
No, no, no, I mean, I think your hair
is taking care of all of the
making fun on all its own.
I mean, especially this lick
that you have going right now.
Look at this, look at this.
I can't--
Look at that!
See that's like a WiFi
antenna right there.
I'm getting 5G right now, look at that.
Look at that, I look like the little girl
in the Dr. Seuss cartoon who wakes up
when the Grinch is there.
You said, you showed me just
before the show you've been,
you went with--
Wow, look at that.
Braids, fantastic.
Mama's (indistinct).
Yeah, that's fantastic.
Will you help me (laughs)?
Please help.
I would love to virtually
give you some help,
but I think you gotta go
back to those hair shops
and let them handle that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I had this done once.
I was up when we did a week of
shows at the Apollo Theater,
some women there I went into their shop,
and they braided my hair,
and I've never felt pain
like that in my life.
In my life, I have mad respect
for people that can do that.
It gives you a natural face lift.
It just pulls everything up.
Yes, I did look like I was
sort of in my late 20s.
But I was in constant pain,
so I'm never doing that again.
Let me ask you how are you as a person?
We'll get into you have I know
35 things going on right now,
different projects, you always
do, you're a very busy guy,
but how are you doing, how's your family?
We're good for the most part.
I'm very fortunate that, like I said,
I live with someone who isn't sick of me,
and we gotta have our routine,
and we're here with the
dogs, and they're fine.
Our kids have been outta
the house for a year now.
And they're living together
actually not too far away,
so we get to see them.
They're like our COVID partners,
you know, we get to go
over there and hang out.
It's cool, it's cool.
So your kids are old enough
to be living out on their own.
Yeah, they're in their 20s now,
so even if they didn't wanna
go, I was like, "You gotta go."
So they're out.
My kids are still very
young, but I made them leave.
I just, I gave them each $120
and I said, "I'll see you in a month."
I think that's good parenting,
because at times like this
when things are very tough
where are they gonna
learn how to toughen up
unless you kick them outta the nest
and make them fend for
themselves like any good Dad?
Yes, I thought it was tough love.
I've had some people say,
"You coulda given them more than 120 each
and they seem pretty young."
I don't think people should
tell me how to run my life.
When I woke up we stilled
lived in America, right?
Thank you!
(both laughing)
Thank you, finally someone who gets it.